okay we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 let's go to our next caller from
the 2 4 0 area code caller from 2 4 0 by
all means tell us your name and where
you're calling from and what your
question is today my name's Noah I'm
calling from Maryland and I like to ask
you about big Reubens comments on the
show okay um one of the comments was um
fiscal implying that big government
somehow like big bad evil thing like I'm
trying to get money out of politics and
I don't know how about that uh well I
know that that they've talked about that
he's he's into small government but
specifically are you talking about I
guess at one point he sort of alluded
pat to the idea that he favors lower
taxes in part because he doesn't want
the government having a ton of money
with which to be huge I mean that was
sort of generally the idea you only
talked the only time you talked about
money in politics was a funny reference
that liberals need to pick what their
enemy is and it was just kind of like a
way to disparage the SJW community okay
that's the only time you mentioned money
in politics that I'm aware yeah no I'm
just not exactly remembering the the
sort of formulation of the argument I
mean is there a specific question that
whether or not it's from that interview
that you have for me on on Paul on
policy maybe that I could answer okay
moving on policy but I'm also I have a
comment about okay so that some
presidency has been that good I'm sorry
that what is it that Durham I don't
really remember presidency has been a
net good okay yeah presidency Annette
good yeah good yeah I don't think it's
lemon breakfast I mean the silver lining
what is said about people being more
aware whether CLE but I don't think it's
not good know and clearly either either
and I thought I've made that pretty
clear I mean I agree like our show is
bigger than ever and if Hillary Clinton
had been elected you know we would have
still had growth since November but we
wouldn't be nearly as big as we are now
and I mean what he's saying is
undeniably true that there are way more
people interested now and we've seen it
Pat I mean were huge protests record
membership sign ups all sorts of stuff
that that we've seen on our end of
related to the show and just related to
politics but I'd still rather for the
good of the world and the country have
had Hillary Clinton win and have the
show not be quite as big you know what I
mean so no I mean I agree with you no I
don't believe and David this is no
secret
Dave knows I don't believe the Trump
presidency has produced a net good but I
agree with him on the silver linings
he's identified I mean I'm guessing you
do too right
all right burger yeah all right Noah
thanks so much for the call really
appreciate it on that note we will take
a break to everybody who's holding and
there's a lot of you we will continue to
take calls after the break stay with us